[Music]
the last time we saw a ballrog it
grievously wounded gandalf are the
heroes of the rings of power ready to
face off against this terrifying demon
the latest trailer for amazon's the
rings of power featured a surprising
cameo at the very end of the footage an
ancient monster known as a balrog makes
a dramatic appearance the reveal is
interesting because technically there
are no balrogs in the stories of middle
earth's second age they exist or at
least one of them does but they just
aren't doing much of anything these
fiery monsters have existed since the
beginning of time according to the
silmarillion some of these angelic
beings known as the mayar became
followers of sauron's original master
the first dark lord morgoth as the book
puts it dreadful among these spirits
were the valarikar the scourges of fire
that in middle-earth were called the
balrogs demons of terror the balrogs
feature heavily throughout the first age
of middle-earth history but when that
age ends and the second age begins they
are destroyed or scattered in the
shattering war of wrath in a letter
written in 1954 tolkien adds they were
supposed to have been all destroyed in
the overthrow of thangorodrim morgoth's
fortress in the north but it is here
found that one had escaped and taken
refuge under the misty mountains so
after the first age the only balrog that
remains alive and identified is the one
hanging out under moria but even then we
don't see it until long after the story
told and the rings of power plays out
while balrogs are busiest in the first
age they have a rather momentous
footnote later in middle earth's history
an appendix to the return of the king
describes the menace haunting moria as a
terror that flying from thangorodrim has
lain hidden at the foundations of the
earth since the coming of the host of
the west a balrog of morgoth the book
also says this happens in the
1980th year of the third age at this
point the balrog is roused by dwarves
who are famously delving too greedily
and too deeply in search of precious
methril when they wake the beast they
set a series of events in motion that
leads to the destruction of their
kingdom this sets the stage for a deadly
duel with gandalf on a slender stone
bridge a little over 1 000 years later
[Music]
what does all of this mean for the rings
of power basically we don't see a whiff
of a ball rock in the source material
amazon primes series is based on so why
do we see a ball rock in the show's
promotional footage apart from
compelling visuals there are a few
different theories for how the demonic
monster could factor into the show's
story
the story of durin's bane the balrog and
moria is one of fearful exile the
creature flees when its master falls and
eventually hides deep under a mountain
for 5 000 years we don't get an account
of how the monster comes to that spot we
only hear that it flees there after
morgoth is destroyed this leaves an
unspecified opening in the story during
which the balrog makes its way to its
place of exile maybe the monster in the
trailer is during's bane as it seeks a
place of refuge deep under the mountains
perhaps it even causes some trouble
along the way after all the silmarillion
says that during the beginning of the
second age men were grievously plagued
by morgoth's sinister monsters it
specifically references unnamed demons
among these creatures which could easily
describe a
foe is beyond denali
if this is the case the showrunners may
have opted to weave the walrog into
their plans not as an opposing force
blocking the path of the heroes but as a
creature running from them it's even
worth noting that a footnote in the
return of the king mentions that the
phrase roused from sleep used to
describe the balrog's awakening could
also mean released from prison if the
ballrog is trapped under the misty
mountains until the dwarves uncover it
maybe we'll witness the initial capture
of the creature on the show
another option the rings of power might
pursue is showing the balrog in a
flashback or even a flash forward in
terms of the former route we know the
balrog flees to the misty mountains at
the end of the first age this is a
period that will likely be recapped
during the show since it's the immediate
backdrop to the story maybe as the show
discusses the war of wrath we'll see a
quick shot of a balrog as it makes its
way into the mountains this might not
even be the same balrog that we see in
moria in the lord of the rings if that's
the case we could be seeing a different
ballrog and a flashback summarizing how
gruesomely terrifying the first age was
if this is another balrog it also stands
to reason that it could be present
during the show as a completely made-up
part of the story then again the shot we
see in the trailer could also be a
prescient flash forward
perhaps someone in the show has a vision
or a dream of the horrors to come at one
point in the trailer the dwarven king
during the third makes a deeply
foreboding statement
beyond the darkness tempting shadow
to bury us all beneath the mountain
this sounds prophetic and it's possible
that this prophecy may refer to a balrog
one of the biggest deviations from the
books in the rings of power is the way
it condenses tolkien's original second
age story into the lifespan of a single
generation
while time will go by as the story
progresses it will do so at a much
faster pace than the actual 3500 years
it takes for the second age to play out
in the text this time compression shows
that the creators are willing to make
significant changes to the story if
that's the case it's reasonable to
believe that they might weave the story
of the awakening of duran's bane into
the narrative of their second age tale
sure it's an event that happens 2 000
years after the rings of power story
ends but when you've already compressed
3 500 years of events into a single
point in time it sounds a lot more
reasonable to explore this important
historical event however fans might feel
about it this does seem like it could be
an option
[Music]